ryan you had a relationship about a
decade ago that
really strained our relationship yeah in
a way
um i don't know i mean we don't have to
mention the person obviously but uh
someone you were dating and there was a
certain toxicity there just
even if you take me out of the
relationship well yeah i think it was
what jamie was talking about earlier
where it was like
uh i was uh to lib quality and she was
like
how dare you go talk to except you were
business partners with to live quality
well you know it's interesting like
i i had been a really crappy
partner up to this relationship yeah so
when i started
dating this this girl this woman i was
like i'm going to give it my
all oh my god this is what happened with
me in the tulip quality like this is
actually wow
so so when she exhibited toxic behavior
i didn't
see it as toxic behavior i looked at it
as
oh i'm doing something wrong because
you're so i could be being
yeah if i could just change it so i did
everything i could
by the way when i met her i was at the
peak of my drug use
this was before uh the minimalist this
is this was like when i was at the peak
of my misery the peak of my drug use the
peak of my
uh you know of my of my uh well heading
towards the peak of like my my corporate
job or career or whatever um so
there was so much going on that a when i
sobered up
i was like uh oh like i didn't realize
how i had to be on drugs to be with this
woman
and then and then i it took me you know
three years to realize like
oh like it is okay to say hey ryan it's
not you
it actually is this other person so it
took me a long time i would do the exact
same thing it was wild yeah yeah it's
rough because yeah because you want to
keep
because it's been on you it was on me
for so long yeah that i wanted to be
like no
this is ryan this is the same thing that
always happens in your relationship and
even when she said the jealousy thing
i was just like i was like i know that's
gonna be okay because i am not even
going to
look at another girl because i am fixing
everything about me and i am ready to be
a perfect boyfriend
that doesn't mean she was ready to be a
perfect girlfriend yeah like and then
look it's good that me and you did that
and then we got to take it on to our
new relationships but man what a bummer
when you're just like
all right i guess this is what a healthy
relationship is as like this
other person is suddenly being crazy and
you're trying to like
be the best version of yourself yeah it
was it was
uh yeah i'll tell you the one thing i
got out of that relationship though
is i realized what i needed out of a
partner
and so when i found that in a partner i
uh yeah it was great i knew exactly i
knew exactly i was like oh yeah like
this is i'm willing to give this a shot
yep
instead of being like i'm gonna find the
person who's gonna show me the most
attention
and then i'm gonna give that a shot it
was like i got a lot more
choosy i guess with the people out there
and she has to pass the um i mean the
apex
the apex i mean just so people know how
it strained josh and i's relationship
the apex
was when we were in salt lake city
and you were dating a girl at the time
yeah colleen yeah the girl that's in
everything that remains yeah and
everything that remains and colleen had
had
some stuff about like hey look uh
she had issues with like she had dated a
married guy or something i don't know
what it was
so josh was still technically married
okay by the way i hadn't been with my
wife for several years yes
they were just like on paper technically
married yeah we hadn't gone through the
court date yet so
had all the paperwork me trying to be
the trying to put it on myself and to
repair this relationship
because she was very jealous over
colleen for some reason because colleen
and i would joke on twitter
ryan and colleen were friends right and
um
the other person ryan's girlfriend just
couldn't understand that ryan could also
be friends with
yeah with with the person i was she just
tells me that she couldn't just be
friends with guys which
which is a whole other other thing
fascinating so i
said hey why don't you have we're in
salt lake city we're on
we're we're in salt lake i'm like why
don't you go and have
some lunch with colleen and just
try and like really see her for who she
is she's a great person
and she was like yeah i'll give that a
shot so she went on this lunch and
basically was like just attacked colleen
you know josh is still married
technically you know that uh you should
probably lose
a few pounds but i was in such a state
that like i thought there's no way she
could do like there's no way she
actually behaved like this
like i just killed this what a great
idea yeah exactly i mean it was like i
mean that was the apex where i mean and
that was real it was really like
that was in like december i think it was
december 20
yeah it was right before christmas and
this is our very first store we had two
people around salt lake city
yep and then we broke up in march like
it was three months later where i was
just like i
but that was the beginning of me like oh
wait a minute this isn't
this is an orion problem right this the
only ryan problem is is that i'm trying
to hang on to something
isn't that a wild first realization
where you're just like i'm not the one
that screwed this up
you're like she tried she she
specifically tried to break up
colleen and josh yeah yeah yeah yeah
went on the friendship and like because
that would probably break you guys out
she was just have you she was yeah well
it got to a point where i was like
again like still trying to hold on i'm
like okay i'm gonna do this couple's
counseling
and we went into like she picked out the
therapist which i'm like okay great but
then
when i went it's like her and the
therapist
were going after me and josh right and
that was like
the third season of ozark do you
remember did you you see the third
season of oh yeah
yeah it's so good spoiler alert he he
bribes the
psychiatrist i totally thought about
this yes
when i saw when i saw the third season
i'm like oh this is what my
ex did to me she found a she found a
psychiatrist or a couples counselor
to basically be on her side that's great
and it was just like and it was like oh
you know josh is in your life but he
needs to be out of your life
whoa yeah he's i'm like what the hell
are you talking about i'm like this is
the worst advice i've ever heard in my
life like there should be some kind of
co-existing
wow like yeah and uh yeah i mean but
that was
again that happened in march and then i
think she gave me an ultimatum
i didn't even break up with her she was
like you need to stop talking to colleen
or we're through and i'm like i guess
we're through then oh isn't that
that was it isn't that the best when you
don't want to get out of a relationship
because like and they get
they give you the ultimatum and you're
like well if that's what you want and
they're like one you're just like no
it's too late you said it all right
i have so much guilt in it guys take it
back you can't take it back don't take
it back
i remember uh with uh the saddest thing
that happened with emma
is i think one of the reasons you know i
talk about like i finally had the guts
to get out of a relationship before i
got toxic
i was so devastated about the cat that
nothing could upset me like there were
literally times where i'd be crying and
i think she thought it was about like
me and her because we were talking about
breaking up and she's like hey it's okay
we'll still be friends and i'm like what
you're still here you'd already be like
i was just like so obsessed about the
cat
that i was just like whatever like
everything else was like easy but anyway
glad you're out of that relationship
yeah me too i have so much like
guilt and anxiety talking about this
it's crazy because it's like resurfacing
all of my
yeah bad mistakes but hey that's what we
do